when I was in Boulder I met a friend of
mine that I haven't seen for 25 years
and asked him what he was up to and what
he's doing is he's founded a company
called Rocky Mountain Media Watch and
what they do is they have a hundred and
fifty people who work for them in the
hundred and fifty cities and once a week
these people make a video cassette off
the TV of the out the evening news the
local evening news hour and they ship
all these tapes to Boulder and they have
rooms full of people watching these
things on screens and scoring how much
of this hour went to ecological stories
how much went to lost pet stories how
much went to toxic waste stories how
much went to the circus is in town
stories and I said well Paul what is the
deal with violence and what's going on
and he said whoa it's very simple we've
seen it thousands and thousands of times
the most fun in a half-hour show the
most violent part of the show occurs
immediately before the longest
commercial and the you are brought to
this state of adrenal excitement and I
said we'll do people enjoy watching
people shot and blown and he said no no
you can put electrodes on them and you
can tell that it raises anxiety and it
raises adrenaline levels but he said the
whole point is then you cut to the
commercial you bring on images of
sexuality of flesh of soft music and of
the product and the product then becomes
associated with the security it's all
about look at this horrible death mangle
and horror now and this wonderful soap
which will give you social confidence
and make your hair shine
your underarms inoffensive and and this
game is played through 400 times a night
with monkeys on the receiving end you
know people who you know take Ross Perot
seriously and fear visits by alien
proctologists that population you know
being subject to this hammering
stimulus-response thing
well it's no it's no wonder that people
are just totally clueless the cultural
engines are becoming almost unmanageably
dangerous for the unsophisticated this
is what I meant last night when I said
there are two kinds of people there are
artists and marks not in a in a tone of
superiority we're the artists and we're
on the inside and so we're immune and
the marks [ __ ] them they're all lost
souls know every one of us every day is
tested to see are you an artist or are
you a mark in this moment are you an
artist or are you a mark in this
situation are you in art history are you
mark and you know everybody tumbles both
ways
several times a day because I don't know
exactly what to do about it I mean
Joseph Goebbels really turning that
loose inside the 20th century I mean
this has all been developed since the
thirties you know advertising techniques
techniques of behavior modification ways
of insinuating complex messages into
people and getting them to respond the
antidote is in that environment you
cannot flee from it you cannot avoid it
what you have to do is
produce output output into this ocean of
competing means output and and
subversion and sophistication you have
to be I think very very this is no
environment for the credulous the
epistemologically naive those driven by
inner imbalances to adoration and belief
I mean I really believe I think I said
last night salvation through skepticism
hope through skepticism because
it's too difficult to tell what's going
on the only reliable indicators in this
world our feelings and mathematics and
mathematics has been torn from you as an
option in the process of infantile
ization that were denouncing here so all
you have left are your feelings 90% of
this